today on the matt walsh show the left
celebrates as the show muppet babies
pushes cross-dressing
on three-year-olds also our five
headlines a member of the squad sets up
her own homeless encampment
outside of the capitol a republican
governor says that kids should mask
in school this is what we're getting
from republicans now robin d'angelo
talks about the time
when she discovered she was white and
this didn't happen until she was in her
30s apparently
the babylon b cyber bullies me i'm a
victim of cyberbullying i'll tell you
why in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about the increasing scourge
of internet panhandlers all of that and
much more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now a quick word from my pillow you know
i am a man
of habit i don't i don't like to switch
things up very
very often and when i find a good zone i
like to stay in that zone and that's why
uh i love it when i find companies that
that provide not just one product that i
like but uh but many products and that's
the case for
my pillow you guys hear me talk about uh
my pillow
every week and how i love the my pillow
products well now my pillow is changing
the game
with their six piece towel set this set
is made with usa cotton making it
extremely absorbent yet still
providing that soft feel that you look
for in a towel
the set comes with two bath two hand
towels and two wash cloths typically
retailing for 109 for a limited time you
can get this set for the low price
of 39.99 that's over 60 percent in
savings and always remember all my
pillow products come with a 60-day
money-back guarantee
you have nothing to lose they come in a
variety of colors and sizes and are the
best towels i have used in years these
are
game-changing towels so go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener square and use promo code
dailywire
at checkout or call 800-651-1148 you'll
receive this amazing six-piece towel set
for just 39.99
that's mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square and use promo code daily
wire
call 1-800-651-1148 use promo code
dailywire or go to mypillow.com make
sure to use promo code dailywire
you know a few years ago if you had said
that we are getting to a point as a
culture where cartoon shows for
preschoolers will openly push
gender non-conformity on three-year-olds
you would have been laughed at and
mocked by almost everyone especially
those on the left
would have accused you of engaging in a
slippery slope fallacy but as we've seen
time and time and time again
if the slippery slope is a fallacy at
all it is only a fallacy
because it assumes that our descent will
be slow and gradual like a man sliding
down a slope as opposed to fast and
cataclysmic
like a man pushed out of an airplane at
35 000 feet
these slippery slope arguments of 10
years ago understated the case they were
far
too optimistic but the basic predictions
if on a faster timeline
have played out in fact before we get to
the preschool shows
we should note that we have our we've
already reached the point
where people are identifying as animals
and not a few people
this is a trend now and and the very
people who would have laughed at you for
predicting it
will now solemnly inform you that it's
your duty to take these hysterical
delusions seriously
as always tic toc gives us a revealing
peek into this particular form of
degenerate madness
so let's take a look i made a really
loud yelly video about this but i
decided i will approach this in a more
calm but stern manner
a lot of the people using kitty and pop
and bunny self pronouns
are neurodivergent miners it is a very
common neurodivergent experience to feel
a disconnect
from being human and from from
the societal expectation of the gender
you were assigned to birth
so when you have this intersection of
feeling a disconnect from being human
and a disconnect from the societal
expectation of gender
whether you're neurodivergent or not a
lot of people have this experience who
are neurodivergent it's just very common
with neurodivergent people when this
intersects you get noun self pronouns
and animal noun self pronouns
if you are not comfortable using
someone's pronouns because
you assume it's kink for some weird
reason
don't interact with them and just shut
up about it
there were of course of course only
about three real words
used during that entire rant but i don't
want to be too harsh in dealing with
this young lady as she was clearly just
assaulted by a violent gang of
permanent markers i don't want to add to
her suffering any case
she says that lots of people these days
are using animal pronouns
including what she calls bunny self
pronouns
just you know according to my quick
google search bunny self pronouns are
bun bunny and bun self so if you run
into any bunnies
that's how you're supposed to refer to
them used in a sentence you might say
bun went to the grocery store or bun is
here and buns brought buns for the
cookout or
hey bun please stop fidgeting while i
put your straight jacket on
if you're not willing to use these
completely made-up words in order to
respect the insane hallucinations of a
mentally ill person who thinks that
they're a budding rabbit
then you are the weird ass now it's not
weird to identify as a woodland creature
and demand that the english language be
changed to accommodate your strange
beastial road role play it's weird to
deny such a request
hey guys i'm i'm a moose now just just
became a moose yesterday
please refer to me as moose moose self
and moose moose
uh what you're you're no you're not a
moose you're a person well calm down
weirdo you pervert
what kind of creep goes around telling a
moose that they're people
now this kind of extreme gaslighting may
seem
too silly to be effective but then you
forget that
lots of people in this country today are
so spineless that they might as well
identify as jellyfish with
i guess gel and gel self pronouns all
you have to do is scream at them and
call them a bigot
and they will do literally anything you
ask them to do there is no
reality they won't deny for the sake of
seeming enlightened
which is why they will also i'm sure
applaud this the show muppet babies a
show specifically targeted at preschool
aged kids
has now introduced its first gender
non-conforming character
um gonzo has begun cross-dressing it
seems and an entire episode of the show
titled gonzarella
revolved around this development early
in the episode while the muppets are
planning to attend
a royal ball for whatever reason gonzo
says that um
he wants to wear a pretty dress to the
ball and he's quickly informed by his
muppet friends that only girls wear
dresses
now in a different time and place that
would have been it
right that would have been a gag for for
the kids to laugh about a male character
wanting to wear a dress
would be seen as funny it would have
been played for laughs because it's
silly
you might have had stuff like that in
kids shows back in the day
or a male character says i'm gonna wear
the dress
and then everyone laughs oh no you're
silly you don't wear a dress
because it's silly for boys to wear
dresses that is in fact exactly what
i've taught my own kids
like for example when my daughter a
couple years ago was out with uh with my
wife and they happened across a man in a
dress
and um my daughter was confused about it
and i i talked to her about it later
and she said to me that the man in the
dress was silly
and i said you're right he was silly
that's silly isn't it men don't wear
dresses dresses are for girls
that's very very silly and that's the
correct way to handle that
i i think a lot of parents they probably
probably even the ones that that
that know that it's silly would still
say to their kids i don't know but we
have to respect
don't don't call it silly that's
disrespectful
that's not my approach i said oh you
know you're exactly right we should
laugh about that it's silly
but it's not how our cultural overlords
at disney want us to handle it so in the
show
um gonzo shows up to the ball in his
dress and becomes the cinderella in
their weird cross-dressing take on the
story
and that all leads to this scene let's
watch
there you are you missed our royal ball
we met the most amazing princess
but they ran away and all they left
behind was this
everyone there's something i need to
tell you
the princess who came to your ball
tonight was me
i'm gonzarella
gonzo why didn't vu tell us
because you all expected me to look a
certain way
i don't want you to be upset with me but
i don't want to do things just because
that's the way they've always been done
either i want to be me oh gonzo
we're sorry it wasn't very nice of us to
tell you what to wear to our ball
you're our friend and we love you any
way you are
yeah yeah of course we do yeah
now think about something here
there have been many film adaptations of
cinderella too many
certainly most of them targeted at older
audiences older kids and adults
none of them have gone so far as to make
cinderella a boy
the closest would be the latest
adaptation to be released on amazon
in which the fairy godmother is a dude
but even in that case the princess and
the prince are your standard traditional
male female duo the point here is that
disney junior is being edgier and going
further with this show targeted at
three-year-olds than with the shows and
movies it makes for older people
and the point is important because we
need to understand that the
indoctrinators are not using
kid gloves with the kids the
indoctrination much like the slippery
slope is not gradual but abrupt and
extreme
they intend to take kids when they're
the most vulnerable the most susceptible
the least able to resist and toss them
right into the deep end of the
propaganda pool
they are not waiting they are not easing
anyone into this they're taking them at
three years old and saying hey
let's start cross-dressing kids
as always of course they will snicker at
us for
making so much out of an episode of
muppet babies
hey it's just the muppet babies calm
down drama queen
or king uh and yet if if you if you
check social media you'll see the left
celebrating this episode of muppet
babies and exclaiming of its beauty and
power
saying that they were brought to tears
of joy by the sight of ganzo in a ball
gown
if you object at all then you're making
a big deal out of nothing
um they say as they pop the champagne
bottle with tears in their eyes
it's a clever trick they can extol the
great significance of a certain event
while at the same time mocking their
critics for acting like it's significant
and this enables them to avoid actually
defending the thing itself which is good
for them because the thing itself is
indefensible you are directly
encouraging young children to
cross-dress
it's the kind of thing that if a man
came up to your son on the playground
and said it hey little boy you ever
tried wearing a dress
it's a lot of fun if a man came up to
your
child your boy your son on the
playground and said that you would
assume he's a pedophile
and you call the police after you
throttle him and punch him in the face
but when disney does it or your kid's
preschool teacher does it
it's supposed to be not only acceptable
but laudable
it's all a mind game it's a mind game
they're playing with adults
and having great success
and if they're having that much success
with adults think about what this is
doing to children because children are
of course
the primary victims of all of this
madness
now let's get to our five headlines
okay so uh a couple quick notes here uh
i do have to let you know
real really big talk about significant
events
um this is a huge moment i think in my
life something i'll never forget
i have uh made it to a hundred thousand
instagram
followers so
you know if you want to send gifts or
anything you can uh big big big big
moment for me
and if you want to follow me on
instagram you go to instagram.com
matt walsh blog where there's uh a lot
of
interesting stuff being put there yeah i
i kind of like instagram because uh
it you know doesn't require a lot of
effort on my part
which maybe isn't the best way to be
pushing this i'm supposed to be selling
it i'm supposed to be promoting that you
go and check out my instagram page
but you got to do that because you know
if you follow me on twitter
if you follow me on facebook if you have
the newsletter mattwallreport.com by the
way
uh you can sign up for the newsletter
and if you listen to the show
and you're subscribed to the daily wire
and you subscribe on youtube
it's it's not enough you need
more ways to get in touch with me and
connect with me and that's why we have
instagram instagram.comwalshblog follow
me there
okay that was my best my best attempt at
pitching it
selling it uh what do we got here so
representative corey bush has quickly
become
somehow the most shameless
attention-hungry charlatan
in congress which is really saying
something especially because she's a
member of the squat she's one of the
newest members of the squad
and i i guess she she showed up and and
they were gonna
induct her into the squad bring her in
bring her into the fold and she knew she
really had to bring her
a game as far as being a shameless hack
and she
she has i mean she has surpassed her
fellow squad members
for that title somehow and now having
already won the title
she's spiking the football she's doing
an end zone dance she's rubbing it in
with this because right now as we speak
she has she has camped out
on the steps of the capitol she has set
up her own
fake homeless encampment in order to
demand an extension to the
eviction moratorium of course she's
choosing to be homeless during a time
when the weather is sunny
in the 70s and 80s and it gets down to a
nice little you know 65 at night
she has all the necessary comforts
including an endless supply of junk food
it would seem
so she's choosing to do this stunt at
that you know when it's it's still quite
comfortable
i'd be a little bit more impressed if it
was like
february with a high of of of 22 degrees
in the middle of the day and she was
doing this a little bit more impressed
um but she's on needless to say
camped out on the steps of the capitol
sleeping out there
this this is not legal okay
this is not something you you could
normally do if you're just a normal peon
show up on the steps and go to sleep
so this is you could argue
another insurrection being perpetrated
by the squad
but let's listen to what she has to say
she's uh outside of the capitol right
now talking to reporters
and uh she's clutching her head in in
pain and agony
crying very authentic tears here's what
she says
triggering but when you hear
the cries of others when you hear the
suffering of others we're
already fighting a battle and losing a
battle
because there are people who slept out
last night the night
the night before there are people who
are already unhoused
and we don't have enough we don't have
enough um
shelters we don't have enough we don't
have the safe housing for them right now
and that's a
failure that's another moral failure on
our society
and so to then say yes seven million
more
you can go while i go on vacation seven
million more
you can hit the go ahead like that was
your decision to be in this position
no no this is a systemic problem
this is a structural problem that can be
handled by better policy decisions
[Music]
so that's why we're out here
uh i i guess i i one question i have
first of all how many oreos does one
person need she is she has a box of
20 bags she's sitting next to a box of
20 packs of oreos
and she had fritos back there
gorging on junk food is that the normal
homeless experience
uh she looks she looks pretty
comfortable out there
but who who exactly are the the these uh
the the people who can't pay their rent
now we know
just in normal course of events
uh there are people who fall on hard
times and are not able to pay their rent
so we know this is something that
happens in general but this this is all
this all stems from the lockdowns and
the pandemic
this again remember it was originally a
cdc policy
although they had no authority
whatsoever to enact any policy like this
um they have no authority in the realm
of
of housing this is originally a cdc
policy connected to the pandemic
so these are people who i guess we're
supposed to assume
you know many people millions of people
thousands of people at least
who were not able to pay their rent
because i guess they lost their jobs
during the pandemic
okay well there are
thousands and thousands
uh millions of open jobs right now
employers are begging people to come and
work for them
so if you're if you're in a position the
eviction moratorium has ended
and you don't have a job you're not able
to pay your rent well go go go
go get a job go go find a job
now there are exigent circumstances
there might be some people
who for whatever reason even though
there are so many jobs available aren't
able to find one but
a good however many people are
being threatened with becoming unhoused
as corey bush puts it
it seems to me a good portion of them
could probably find jobs because
the jobs are out there
waiting to be scooped up
and you could talk to almost any
employer and they will tell you
they've got plenty of jobs and they
cannot convince people to take them
but all of that not to replay everything
we talked about yesterday
and it's hard for me not to because i
find i i find this so infuriating
these crocodile tears that she's
shedding
uh for for the people who are now
squatters refusing to pay their rent
by the way if you talk to to landlords
and i and i have
a lot of them will tell you hey you know
the the uh
that's the stimulus payments came and it
was supposed to go towards these kinds
of living expenses
and i didn't see it because my tenants
you know they went out and bought new
tvs
and they bought new cell phones they
didn't pay their rent
because you give the stimulus payments
in order to take care of living expenses
at the same time you're saying
the government says oh well you don't
have to pay your living expenses
so there and i'm not saying it's the
case for all of them but there's a a
certain
probably not small portion of the people
who've not been paying their rent and
are facing eviction now
who could have paid it and chose not to
but whether they could have or they
couldn't
you know these crocodile tiers for
squatters while
the people who own the property
have have faced immense financial
hardship
it was hard enough for a lot of people
to just support themselves you know if
you
lost your job or took a pay cut or lost
hours during the lockdowns
well you you know it's hard enough to
take care of yourself and pay for
yourself now now imagine if you had to
support
other like whole entire other families
whole apartments of people
that now now it was on you to take care
of them
while you were also losing income just
like they did
but that again is the kind of compassion
we get from the left all right here's
some audio to play for you here's uh
biden's top covet advisor saying that
masks
at least the masks that people are
wearing and have been wearing through
this entire thing
don't really work this is him saying it
not me
this is the biden's covet advisor here
he is on cnn
we know today that many of the face
cloth coverings that people wear are not
very effective in reducing
any of the virus movement in or out
either you're breathing out or you're
breathing in
and in fact if you're in the upper
midwest right now anybody who's wearing
their face cloth covering can tell you
they can smell all the smoke that we're
still getting we need to talk about
better
masking we need to talk about n95
respirators which would do a lot
for both people who are not yet
vaccinated or not previously infected
protecting them
as well as keeping others who might
become infected
having been vaccinated from from
breathing out the virus
here's the thing everything you just
heard there i
if i said that
i'd probably get kicked off of youtube
but we we're we're not allowed if we say
that that's misinformation
only uh a a bureaucrat
wearing a suit and tie on cable news
he's allowed to say that but we can't
so i guess i have to phrase this a
certain way
it would seem according to him
that these masks that um many millions
people have been wearing
are functionally useless and you might
say that it was obviously that was
always obviously the case
okay you might say that like what
exactly
are we hoping to accomplish all these
people with just pieces of cloth
over their face or wearing bandanas
i mean that was that was one of the at
least for me where i live that was one
of the most one of the primary forms of
face covering that i saw for months and
months was people would just ban
they look like um you know train car
robbers from 1847
with bandanas around their face
and it's it's the the bandana is hanging
down and it's just kind of
flapping in the wind
what what exactly is that supposed to do
or the neck gator you know what and
that's that's had
you know back when when we were forced
to wear masks everywhere that was the
one that i chose
the neck because you just kind of pull
it up over your face and then when no
one's looking you can take it back down
but i always thought to myself the only
reason i'm doing this is because i need
to get into this grocery store and get
some groceries and they won't let me in
if i don't wear it
i do not i i do not imagine that i'm
actually preventing
any illnesses from infecting me with
this little piece of cloth over my face
anyway that's what he seems to be saying
and you might agree with it or you might
not who knows
all right let's go next to uh mike
dewine republican governor of ohio
who says now that uh he is calling on
all schools to require
children to wear masks once again this
is the republican governor of ohio here
he is
we came out last week with
recommendations there are
recommendations we leave it up to the
local schools
600 some local schools we leave it up to
them but we have a strong recommendation
that because the population in school
kids in school most of them are
unvaccinated
you know obviously we can't get any by
11 and under vaccinated yet
so most of these kids are unvaccinated
and we had great success last
last winter last school year we saw
virtually no spread in the classroom
when all the kids were wearing masks so
we recommend strong recommendations to
our schools
that they do that now some will do that
some will not but
it's clear the evidence shows that
that's a way to really slow down
spread in the school and we think it's
very important
so i say this and i want you to know i
don't mean it as a compliment
this guy mike dewine is the perfect
republican
absolutely a perfect representative of
the republican party i cannot think of a
better one
just this totally unimpressive empty
nothing of a person
going along with you know not not not
taking any kind of stand here at all
and just saying uh sure sure yeah i mean
put put put the kids in masks for
all day every day for an entire year
yeah why not
that's that's the best you're going to
get from their from the the republican
party
most of the time um
in fact there was a chris christie gnome
a couple of days ago she sent out a
tweet speaking of unimpressive
republican governors
she sent out a tweet uh uh talking about
the the employers who
would require vaccine mandates and she
said she was taking a stand against that
by saying
well listen if you're an employee at one
of these places
and your employer is requiring that you
get a vaccine mandate
um then then i i encourage you to go and
find another job well hold on you're the
governor of the state
can't you do a lot better than that how
about using your power
to prevent these companies from having
that kind of requirement
because it's an infringement on privacy
it's a hipaa violation
there there are you know many angles you
could approach it from
how about using the power that you have
if you're actually concerned
about people losing their job for this
reason
that's a republican party for you okay
next we got robin d'angelo um she's the
nutty hack who wrote
white fragility and then she wrote
another book recently that
i guess nobody read um i don't think
anyone's actually read white white
fragility either
by the way it sold a lot of copies i
don't i think probably 10 people have
read it but it sold a lot of copies
um the other book didn't even sell any
copies she was on some kind of show or
podcast
recently i don't even know what show
this is doesn't matter and this is the
conversation
that occurred listen to this talk to me
about when you first realized you were
white
and whiteness yeah talk to me about that
um
i i it was a very abstract sense
i i honestly believe i was about um 34
years old
i was college educated i was a parent
um and someone handed me peggy
mcintosh's article
yeah and i read through that list
and i had an out-of-body experience i
could tell you where it was sitting
i i i'm not ever going to forget that
moment where
all of a sudden i was like oh my god i'm
white
and i felt so loudly white that i
remember
being hesitant to go outside i didn't
want to go outside
because everybody could see that i was
white
well here's the thing robin we could see
it before you realized
we could see it all along
you have to laugh about it because
uh the other option is crying and i've
already made clear that men should not
cry
but we can laugh at how insane this is
but this is what this is this is this is
what people this is what kids are being
taught in school
as whiteness is it's like a disease
realizing that you're white i mean she
talks about it if you didn't have any
frame of reference
and you take out a couple of the words
here and there that she uses you you
would think she was
recounting the time when she got the
test results back and found out that she
had
uh breast cancer or something she she's
talking about it like it's
a disease because that's how she sees it
and that's what and that's what this is
what critical race theory brings it's
what kids in school are being taught
about themselves to hate themselves
and whiteness it's not just you know
it's this kind of
it's like this spiritual concept
it's apart from skin color but also it's
connected to your skin
color it's a it's a spiritual
affliction that is passed down by your
ancestors to you
uh does anything good happen from that
i mean where does that go when you when
you raise
entire generations of people entire
races of people
to hate themselves and be self-loathing
where does that head is there any
historical analog for that
for that working out well for society
all right here's also this from uh nbc
chicago this is from this from last week
but this ties directly back
to the cancellation yesterday
and it says a series of lgbtq rights
bills signed by illinois governor jb
pritzker will reverse archaic laws and
change the way county clerks issue
marriage licenses as the governor said
prisker signed four bills that will
expand rights to the lgbt community
community
um one of them has the one of the most
historic hb
1063 will make illinois only the second
state in the country
second to california we talked about
california yesterday to completely
reverse the criminalizations
criminalization of um of those living
with the hiv virus that at least anyway
that's the way it's being framed
that in the past it had been criminal to
have hiv had been criminalized and now
we are reversing the criminalization
well that's not the case at all it was
it was not a criminal act
to have hiv in illinois prior to this
here's what
here's what actually was the case um
before the bill signing
you could face prison time and thousands
of dollars in fines if you didn't
disclose your hiv status to your
intimate partner
advocates say the law discriminated
against marginalized communities and
prevented people
from getting tested fearing legal
repercussions for knowing their hiv
status
and so now it is no longer illegal
it's not that it's no longer illegal to
have hiv i think we can all agree that
it shouldn't be illegal to have
any virus and it isn't anywhere in the
country
but prior to this bill it was illegal to
knowingly
expose someone else to the virus without
telling them
and now it's not it is no longer a
felony
you can participate in an act
with someone that is highly likely to
transmit to them
a deadly virus and not
tell them and not get their consent
and it's not a felony anymore
this is a this is it we talked yesterday
yesterday about california and they
passed that law that that change in
their law
i think was back in 2017 or 2018 so
three or four years ago
um i actually didn't realize some people
in the comments pointed out that
illinois had just passed a similar law
last week
i didn't even realize that that somehow
it's escaped my notice
but there's a very interesting dichotomy
between this and all the masking stuff
because in california they're bringing
mass mandates back
now in illinois they're also talking
about bringing the mass mandates back or
at least masking guidelines encouraging
people to wear masks
so think about the contrast here
that what they're saying and we again we
talked about this yesterday
um and dr fauci and others don lemon
have been
have been very upfront and and explicit
about this
that you don't have the right to expose
other people
to any potential diseases that you have
which means that you should wear a mask
presumably forever and just never take
it off covet or no covered
because that's the that's the
implication that's the precedent that's
being said
so um you're infringing on people's
rights if you
walk through the store without a mask on
but you could have sex with you could be
hiv positive have sex have
even unprotected sex with someone
and uh being nearly guaranteed to
transmit it to them
and not tell them and that's not an
infringement on rights
if you needed more proof that all the
the the
the justifications that were given for
mass mandates
are hypocritical and contradictory if
you need more proof of that then then
here it is
all right five finally the babylon b is
a site that
i like i'm a fan of it but um i'm not a
fan of targeted harassment which is what
they have subjected me to and i got to
call them out on this
here's a headline on babylon b posted
this weekend it says report
matt walsh mad about something
and this is not the first time i've been
targeted you know they also had a while
back
they had another one that said porn
addiction ended by new law that requires
matt walsh's disapproving face
to appear on all adult sites and then
this
leaked security footage shows matt walsh
attending yoga class
now let me tell you something babylon b
bullying is not a joke
hate crimes are not a joke am i mad
about something yeah i'm mad about the
marginalizing language that you're using
about me
i'm mad about fake news and
misinformation
i'm mad about oppression especially the
oppression that i suffer at your hands
and for the record by the way the yoga
class didn't even have security cameras
i know i checked so just more lies
i got you there let's move on now to our
read the youtube comment section this is
from jesse richards who says
matt instead of saying let's move on to
reading the youtube comments you should
say you should
instead go let's see what my sweet
babies have to say
how about you don't tell me how to do my
job you're banned from the show
but thanks for listening jonah says i
can't stop imagining matt locked up in a
dark closet at the daily wire studio
being fed dog food through a flap
and then drugged up for the duration of
the show before being sedated back into
his neutral form
who told you about this this has never
been made public
haley says um i literally have 50 pounds
of old-fashioned oats in my pantry right
now the sale was just too good
thanks costco 50 pounds
of oatmeal how much oatmeal are you
eating
how that's that's like decades it would
take to get through that much
and the thing is you know it's one thing
if you bought 50 pounds of oats and it
was like five bucks
you probably spent how much did you
spend on that probably spend like 50
bucks on that
this is what costco does to people um
commander corb says at this point being
burned at the stake doesn't sound so bad
only he spelled steak s-t-a-e-a-k
uh which yeah i mean being burned at one
of those kinds of steaks
sounds downright delicious in fact so i
agree with you there
uh james says dear sweet daddy walsh
what do you think about
physician-assisted suicide
it's not funny but you know
there there are i know i have encouraged
this name sweet daddy but uh sweet daddy
walsh but
there are times when when maybe i
wouldn't use that name there are
subjects
where it doesn't seem very appropriate
and uh this might be one of them
what do i think about physician-assisted
suicide i think that physicians should
be in the business of treating and
healing
uh that is if that is after all the
hippocratic oath
that's what they swear to do and i think
they should only be in that business
so that is my radical view of doctors i
think the only thing they should do
this is it is treat and heal
afflictions diseases illnesses injuries
okay that's the only thing they should
do
they should never directly cause harm
on purpose to a person
uh unless that heart unless we're
talking about chemotherapy or something
and the harm is in the
is in the is all part of an effort to
treat an illness um they certainly
should not be in the business of
directly killing anybody
and that includes through physician
suicide and it includes through abortion
so that's my view on that
uh tyler says hey matt simple trick i
use for converting kilograms to pounds
is to double it then add 10 percent
so 10 kilograms times 20 equal times 2
equals 20 20 plus
10 percent equals 22 pounds i think
technically one kilogram is 2.203 or
something pounds but it's a pretty
accurate way to convert
for any weight lifting weights see that
just confuses me more
this is why i was terrible in math
classes because any you know i had
tutors
who would sit me down and say okay well
here's an easy way to think of this
and the easy way to think of it always
made me more confused
because i'm very stupid zelmo says as a
seven foot man i'm offended that you
suggested we're just automatically
supposed to go to the nba
you have attacked an extremely
marginalized group literally 40 of us in
the entire us
i demand an apology and for you to
recognize my lived experience
ducking under door frames and barely
fitting on airplanes while wearing two
small shoes
just know if you ban me from the show
you'll lose literally your biggest fan
shame on you wait is that true though
backing up there are only 40 people in
the whole us that are seven
feet or or higher or
larger because here's i don't want to
make you feel worse about this thing but
if that's true that there are only
47 footers in the entire country as you
claim
this is your community so i'll defer to
you there also there have to be at least
39 in the nba
so zelmo you're literally the only seven
foot guy in the country who didn't make
it to the nba
tough break man tough break uh and
finally bill dow says matt it's been a
while since we've had any poo sheist
updates and i'm beginning to become
concerned well bill
uh i thank you for asking and you know
honestly nobody ever asks me about
pooh or frankly how i'm doing now that
my guy poo was locked up
and that's pretty hard on me personally
as for the latest i did look it up and
it's not good um the website hip hop dx
has this it says poo scheisse is
currently locked up in a miami-dade
federal jail for the foreseeable future
and according to 3-6 mafia affiliate
crunchy black that's exactly how it
should be
during a recent interview with dirty
glove bastards off the porch series
fellow memphis native crunchy black
boldly states
jail is where push isd belongs
considering his alleged involvement
in the october 2020 shooting incident in
the bay harbor island area so
pooch isd crunchy black dirty glove
bastard we're starting to see
sort of our our modern mount rushmore
come together
although i can't tell if these are
people or street slang for
methamphetamine
but um crunchy black is unfortunately
throwing
push isd under the bus we have some of
the footage of that let's uh let's watch
it
look at this he just got in the game
he's already jumping out the car
robin you guys allegedly
yeah and whatever but uh never said
we saw that you know
[Laughter]
legend but bruce i said everybody you
know i'm saying
i'm just saying he did it it was him you
know
i ain't gonna act like they wasn't him
y'all can't act like that but that was
precisely
you know they can't lock him up because
i said it was him
i could be still alive you know what i'm
saying i'm just saying
lies damned lies i never thought i'd see
the day
when crunchy black turns on push isd
what's next crunchy black
are you gonna throw spotum got him under
the bus
what about little dirk who appeared on
pooh's iconic anthem
back in blood gonna give him up to the
feds too
these young men have done nothing wrong
these are men of dignity
and grace they are gentlemen
and you sir are scoundrel
this has been one of the weirder reading
the comment sections that we've done uh
so let's quit while we're behind
you know this past weekend vaccine
passport protests in berlin turned
violent when police decided to start
batoning innocent women and children
pretty disturbing if you saw that
footage
why were they doing that because it
hurts the narrative that they've been
spinning
the narrative that cares only about how
easy you are to control
it's a blatant transparent show of
authoritarianism and if you think it
can't happen in america you're
certainly wrong about that that's why
there's never been a better time to
to pick up ben shapiro's new book the
authoritarian moment the book does a
deep dive into the history of
authoritarianism
how it's creeping into our own
government and then really the most
important thing is what we can do to
stop it
so it's time to learn how to stop our
tyrannical government in
tracks the authoritarian moment is
available now at amazon barnes noble
or any other major bookseller also if
you want to know what it's like to be in
the presence
of the always trending candice owens
then you're in luck because now you can
enter to win a free trip to meet her
and be part of her live studio audience
and you can bask
in her presence as i myself have done if
you sign up now as a daily wire member
with code vip you'll get 25
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win
a trip for two to the daily wire studios
to see candace live
not only will you be meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio and front row seats to watch her
destroy
the left's insidious ideology on her
talk show candace
so go now uh to win two vip tickets to
see candace live and meet her
you can go to dailywire.com subscribe
using code vip for
25 off now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so today we're going to cancel um
panhandlers beggars vagrants
and i don't mean the people who stand on
the median strip with a sign or
come up to you in the parking lot at
walmart or sit on the sidewalk with a
jar
that's the old-fashioned panhandling say
what you want about it but at least
they're asking for money face to face
in person also almost all of them are
drug addicts or severely mentally ill or
both
these are desperate broken people um i
don't often give
them money because frankly i don't
really want to fund someone else's
crack addiction um or my own i don't
know i said someone else's crack
addiction like i have one but anyway
uh but but i'm i'm not mad about being
asked
so that's not what we're talking about a
far worse category of beggar
is the internet beggar and i'm i'm also
not talking here about the person in
legitimately desperate straits trying to
raise money to pay for their child's
medical treatments or something like
that
i'm obviously not talking about people
who raise money for other people for
charitable causes especially if they're
raising money for
say needy abuelas i'm talking about the
rising tide of people
who beg the internet for money for
frivolous reasons or for no stated
reason at all people who start gofundmes
for themselves despite not being in any
dire need in fact when i did that abuela
fundraiser
out of the kindness on my heart i got
messages from dozens and dozens of
people
sending me their own gofundmes and
asking sometimes demanding
that i share their gofundmes and raise
money for them
often their causes were things like
please pay my student loans or
please give me money so i can go on
vacation that was a real one someone
actually asked me to do that
or or help me sir i need money to get my
car detailed
i made the last one up but it's not far
from the kinds of campaigns i've seen
and we should also say that that even
some of the fundraising campaigns
stemming from actual tragedy or
affliction are at a minimum
some of them sort of weird and
inappropriate and off-putting
because these days when someone suffers
a misfortune especially if that
misfortune generates some attention
online
the first thing they often do is start a
gofundme even if it isn't really clear
how money is going to help them in their
situation or why they're asking for it
the pitch seems to be something bad
happened to me uh
and now please everyone give me money to
make yourselves feel better about it
now this is all pretty objectionable but
at least it's better than another form
of cyber panhandling in which a person
simply puts their cash app or venmo
handle
in their bio on social media and asks
people to send the money
for no reason often these days the
panhandler doesn't bother with a sob
story or any story
they just preemptively ask the whole
internet for money and hope for the best
and even that is better than the latest
innovation something i've noticed more
and more recently
and i saw it again yesterday in a
shopping center parking lot
perhaps you've seen this yourself people
who put their cash app or venmo handles
on the rear windshield of their cars
soliciting donations from anyone in the
world who happens to park near them
or end up behind them in traffic the car
i saw yesterday had the person's cash
app information
along with a brief message indicating
that she's a single mother and
any little bit helps me didn't say she's
homeless he didn't say anything just
said single mother any little bit helps
apparently just the simple fact of being
a single mother regardless of your
actual financial situation
is supposed to be enough to justify
public solicitation
i'm a single mother give me money why
why should i i'm a father of four why
don't you give me money
now i wasn't sure if this windshield
trend was something that i was just
noticing myself maybe these people are
following me around
to torment me specifically i don't know
but it turns out that's not the case i
looked it up and found a recent article
from the washington post on this very
subject indicating that it is indeed a
national trend
it says quote when corey roy was heading
out on the final leg of a road trip to
celebrate her wife's
29th birthday in april she decided to
add a message to the rear window of her
hyundai
help us get to new orleans she wrote
adding her venmo and cash up accounts
roy an austin-based hip-hop artist who
goes by mama duke
said in a interview that she was
inspired by fellow road trippers on
tick-tock even 20 dollars would be
better than nothing roy figured
but there was reason for optimism over
the past few months social media users
especially in tic toc
have been sharing their own experience
of venmo powered road trips as travel
has revved up again
users have sought and received
contributions from strangers for
graduations birthdays bachelorette
parties anniversaries
even divorces some of the videos have
been viewed millions of times
now the article gives several examples
including one car spotted by a
journalist
who posted it to twitter which said um
just divorced
buy me a drank d-r-a-a-a-a-n-k
then it had her venmo well at least the
divorce is no mystery here
i mean shameless and greedy is not a
recipe for success in any human
relationship at least of all marriage
one other example from the article a
woman named alyssa harris had the bright
idea to start panhandling
for her bachelorette party um it says
quote
during a stop early on she wrote a
message on the back of the car as she
had seen a fellow tick tock user do
it said quote last fling before the ring
buy the bride a drink
a friend shot a video and they posted to
tic toc during the drive it blew up so
fast that harris a dental hygienist she
had her phone propped up on a stand in
the car for directions
but then venmo notifications kept
flashing
i was like oh my gosh guys every time i
checked there was another hundred
dollars
while she thought a few hundred dollars
might come in i've seen what tic toc can
do she said
she was floored when the total topped 3
200
yes well who could think of a more
worthy charitable cause than sending
money to a random dental hygienist so
that she can have a fun bachelorette
party
people in her line of work have salaries
up to a hundred thousand dollars a year
a good number of the people who sent her
money probably make
less than she does but she accepted it
without shame
and that's the common theme here a total
lack of shame
so what is the problem granted if people
are stupid enough
to give their money to some flagrant
money grubber who put their personal
financial information
on the windshield of their car or post
posted to their twitter bio or to tick
tock
that's their own fault right true but
even so there's reason to be concerned
that people in our culture have become
so comfortable
begging the world for money even when
they don't really need it and are hardly
pretending to need it
to understand the problem consider this
consider this
how many of these moochers would
actually go up to a stranger
face to face and say hey will you give
me some money
why why do you need it oh uh no reason i
i just want some i guess
i'm gonna go party later and i you know
i just i didn't want to spend my own
money
on the party so maybe i could spend
yours
how many would do that almost none of
these people would
and yet that's what they do online or on
their windshields or on their tic toc
accounts
now this of course is a far-reaching
problem on the internet people saying
things
they would never say in person acting in
ways they would never act in front of a
physical audience and whatever you find
yourself doing or saying anything behind
the shield of your screen or keyboard
that you would never even think about
doing or saying to another human in the
flesh
you should really stop yourself and ask
why in the case of the panhandlers
they wouldn't do it in person because
it's shameful and embarrassing and
pathetic
to solicit money from strangers when
you're not in desperate need
and are not giving them anything in
exchange
doing it online is not any less shameful
or embarrassing or pathetic but it does
insulate you from those emotions and
that's maybe that's that's one of the
primary dangers of the internet
is it insulates you from from the
emotional consequence
of the things that you're doing and
saying
now soliciting money from strangers
even when you do need it and are
actually desperate can still be quite a
humbling experience
if again you're making these pleas in
person
it should be humbling there's nothing
wrong with asking for help if you need
it but
it's something that should be approached
with humility you're going up to a
stranger and asking that they give to
you while you offer nothing in return
there is a time and place for that sort
of plea
but the fact that you're asking them to
make 100 of the sacrifice for your sake
when they don't even know you should
again bring forth within yourself a deep
sense of humility
it's that deep sense of humility that's
lost among so many of the cyber
panhandlers there is no sense of
humility
they feel no mortification and receiving
money in exchange for nothing
as long as the money comes from faceless
nameless people who do not have to
salute who they don't have to solicit
personally nor think personally
or thank at all entitlement
shamelessness laziness these all
are the hallmarks of modern american
culture and so it is no surprise that we
have produced a legion of comfortable
well-fed well-dressed internet hobos
using their 900 iphones to clink their
jars to the world
pleading that we might spare some change
though they have plenty of spare change
themselves
i will not give these people a dime but
i will tell them
you're canceled and we will leave it
there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical directors austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by niko geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
john bickley here editor-in-chief of
daily wire wake up every morning with
our new show
morning wire on today's episode an
olympic update
the eviction moratorium expires and the
taliban seizes control of half of
afghanistan
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with
our show morning wire